[Applaudissements]
yangon
je suis très très heureux de te voir
qu'une légende ce que je tu te rends
compte que tu es le recordman du monde
de participation a ajouté lee c'est à
dire que tu vas au statut de la pâte et
un langage
du monde espagne
mais si incroyable est ce que tu te
rends compte de ça mais je peux me dire
qu'on ait fait personne en individuel
well as gagné autant de démission que
moi dans un jeu télé c'est la folie je
voudrais juste dire je suis ravi de
l'argent et surtout de rencontrer
isabelle à ce que j'ai entendu qu'elle
avait dit beaucoup de choses positives à
mon égard donc je voulais les remercier
en personne alors s'il fallait de bruno
serrée qu'elle te suit elle tu adores et
nous aussi on écrit tu vois c'est
vraiment un événement trois petites îles
l'événement du jour vraiment je te le
dis premier plus grands canyons de
gentili en france 92 coup de maître 9
étoile mystérieuse dans la légende bon
ça veut dire qu'il a gagné plein de
trucs 252 participation ta première
participation c'est le vosgien janvier
2021 c'est vrai presque neuf mois de
présence à l'antenne en fait il ya
justement les gens posent une question
c'est que toi ta vie tu avais un travail
ou pas absolument mais que j'ai perdus
en cours d'émission c'est ça pourquoi
parce que tu es tu es trop dans
l'émission non il y avait un plan dans
l'entre-temps mode si je compte faire un
plan il ya
douze coups de midi
vous allez être les records manu monde
d'après station la balle courte non mais
donc et donc l'attenté ali la bam c'est
un énorme rêve nantes arrive le premier
jour est ce que tu te dis tu vas vivre
une aventure comme ça qu'ils étudient au
départ tu t'inscris pourquoi en bresse
j'espérais quand même gagné un petit peu
pourquoi c'est que on se regardait
l'émission je me disais j'ai
l'impression que j'arrive à peu près
souvent à répondre et puis j'avais déjà
eu un record dans un précédent jeu
personne n'y avait pensé avec cyril
féraud bien sûr donc je pensais que
j'avais à peu près un niveau acceptable
pour faire un jeu télé donc j'espérais
quand même en gagner deux ou trois alors
mais c'est vrai que évidemment on se
projette pas du tout en se disant je
vais tenir neuf mois et battre tous les
records à on va on a plein de questions
à se poser sur que les téléspectateurs
aussi juste on va voir ta première dans
l'émission c'était donc le 20 janvier
regarde
lanta je tends les invendus alimentaire
grâce à son appui anti-gaspillage ayant
nager avec des requins bruno 29 ans
j'aimerais trouver l'amour avant ses 30
ans
29 ans l'amour avant 30 ans cinq ans
selim
familièrement l'ensemble des conquêtes
d'un logement et son tableau de chasse
et bien mesdames et messieurs
aujourd'hui venu de fonds tony proches
colomiers le hoggar est née bruno deux
vielles m demi
[Applaudissements]
en émotions labéda
on voit on le sait puisque 1 millions 26
mille euros 107 de gains on sait que
trouver l'argent parce que tu as trouvé
l'amour non toujours célibataire à 30
ans mais tu as tu vas trouver l'amour
que nadir pas réussi à trouver avant mes
30 ans dont va très bien maintenant avec
un million ça peut-être plus facile
[Rires]
et on te croit dès la première quand tu
gagnes pas que dit le pr la première
fois que tu dis est maître de midi où
son petit tu es dedans ben oui on parce
qu'on n'est jamais sûr en vrai si ça va
le faire ou pas et dès que jean-luc dit
vous devenez maître de midi là on se dit
allez tout va s'enchaîner et quoi qu'il
arrive ma vie sera plus la même on sait
pas combien de temps va durer dix au
pire je peux me le racontait en disant
j'ai été maître de midi un jour c'est la
classe et quand même on s'est rendu
compte tu savais tout surtout comment tu
fais c'est quoi ton truc que tu lis tous
ou tu sais quoi c'est j'adore lire en
effet depuis toujours avec toi
non mais dès que des gens pas d'un sujet
que je maîtrise pas ça m'énerve et la
soirée sur wikipédia je lis tout l'a
perdu sur aucun par des noirs du fou
j'ai peut-être une mémoire supérieure à
la moyenne c'est vrai que ça aide mais
après c'est un travail assez comme je
l'avais vu ça avant ou pas où tu écoutes
est un phénomène non mais je suis fan de
jeux télé suis fan de quiz de trial
poursuite donc en fait je m'entraîne
envirogaz amis veulent encore jouer avec
toi parce que moi là c'est difficile
assure et rien pour ces fuites ont
maintenant franchement c'est une galère
du zoo avec toi alors on va on va revoir
quand d'une compil de tes meilleures
réponses alors certaines faciles
d'autres beaucoup moins si c'est là
qu'on voit l'éclectisme de bruno
cloutier
qui est la déesse des chevaux et des
cavaliers chez les gaulois epona
quel écrivain tchèque naturalisé
français a écrit l'un soutenable
légèreté de l'être mylan kundera ou it
up qu'ellroy amateurs de poule au pot
fut assassiné par ravaillac henri iv oui
dans quel pays x se trouve le territoire
du yukon le canada
quel homme de guerre breton prénommé
bertrand fut fait connétable de france
en 13 170 du guesclin
[Musique]
mais quoi vous enchaînez
fois de très bon et il faut que ça
devienne évident attitude et klein mois
la verrait déjà les parents et les
angoisses des caméras il faut maîtriser
ça aussi merci vous faites une très
bonne et
moi
vous étiez pas nier aujourd'hui merci
non mais c'est vrai basketteur
je me tourne à bouger mais tout ce qu'il
fait là
mais c'est important mais c'est
important pour les gens me sens alors
bruno dhont avec 325 1000 euros de
cadeaux ah oui absolument de quoi il
parle car plein de voitures ouais bah
j'aime la voiture telle est ma console
un bar qui
ça se revend petit à petit sortir aux
tirs au but bah oui je n'ai pas gardé de
neuf voitures je pense que personne a
besoin de neuf voitures grâce à des
banquiers
moi je ne suis pas du tout nos voitures
non on dit c'est
promis
c'est quoi comme voiture s'est alors
y'en a qui peuvent intéresser ou alors
il ya une très grosse devant une ford
mustang d'allonger encore 7000 euros
voilà 100 % électrique makli et sinon
c'est plus des voitures de ville des
sujets qui à mal des ford fiesta puis
marc non mais utilise hamidou toutes ces
voitures là pour l'instant y en a
plusieurs que ce soit à tour reçu parce
que leurs tacles et élimine alan wake on
vient de ce que c'est intéressant pour
les téléspectateurs tu as été éliminé
aujourd'hui ouais mais l'émission est
enregistrée et ça fait même très un sens
puisque c'est le prix pour perdu le 16
juillet 7 juillet enregistre et le 16
juillet et ma défaite alors aujourd'hui
donc si je comprends bien brouillon donc
le 16 juillet tu es éliminé exactement à
rien 2 on n'a rien ni en argent ni
enquête si puisque là mon parcours était
tellement long way faty paye trois mois
après ce que j'ai touché donc c'est à
dire que ce que j'ai gagné dans les
émissions diffusées en janvier j'étais
l'un cheikh en avril oui j'ai donc en
fait avril tous les mois je reçois un
chèque est pris à moi démission allez
belle histoire sympa et on l'assumé
chômé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
et donc aider les voitures aussi tu les
recevait examen on a su la testarossa
c'est ce qui
m'est donc ouais donc si ça passe et de
la logistique font les assurés l'asie
matricule air mais c'est vrai que ça
peut compter sur le salaire ça nous
coûtait losail quand même tout ça va on
se plaint pas non plus mais non mais non
mais ça va passer un peu de logistique
mes parents viennent y monte sur paris
on récupère la voiture on redescend avec
royal c'est cool comme les mégots et
elle est folle ta vie je recommence vous
êtes passionné contre moi parce qu'on
vit là il ya eu le 25 septembre dernier
et a passé la barre symbolique du
million d'euros de gains sur on a en
fait dit on à 100 questions à se poser
en commun là je te dis c'est une espère
avoir ce que tu vas faire ou sartre non
mitzach tu va nous donner un peu
d'oseille qu
[Rires]
est-ce que bruno
la haute garonne de l'occitanie
dépasse 1 million d'euros
les créateurs d'astérix se sont inspirés
pour le personnage de cleo bad
[Musique]
les habitants
[Applaudissements]
hong kong 25 septembre avait passé la
barre du million est ce que tu te
regarde parfois quand je suis chez mes
parents mes grands-parents qui l'a
évidemment ils sont à fond ils regardent
ils enregistrent donc là je regarde avec
eux et parfois si je suis tous tout seul
chez moi que je fais une grasse mat et
que je loupé le début je me dis tant pis
elle cause de confidentialité tu pouvais
pas le dire quand et éliminer bien sûr
exactement l'avantagé c'est que
maintenant quand ya pas de public il ya
des accompagnants en visio d'accord donc
on fait mieux était forcément au courant
puisque vu qu'ils avaient prévu le
planning et qu'on leur dit bah non là ça
s'arrête là donc il ya plus besoin de
mes proches proches en tout cas été au
courant puisque le savez qu'il ya plus
de vision à l'été a été gardé alors là
tu gagnes la cubaine plus d'un million
d'euros là c'était quand on passe à jour
1 million d'euros après je les lis tu as
gagné plus de 1 million 26 minoru qu'est
ce quelle réaction de tes parents tes
grands parents ta famille c'est quoi
quand ils voient que ça commence à
exploser côté aujourd'hui le plus grand
gagnant de l'histoire de la télé
française le plus grand nombre de
participations je le répète mondiale au
monde à s'adapter le plus grand gagnant
au monde mais qui a fait le plus
d'émissions son monde c'est fou s'est il
dispose sont fiers de toi ils disent
quoi éviter qu'ils ont peur pour toi non
ça va parce que normalement je suis bien
entouré je garde les pieds sur terre
quoi qu'il arrive donc je vais pas être
en mode star system tous claqué de leurs
vacances
j'apprends des erreurs des hommes
c'est surtout de la fierté non ils n'ont
pas trop de craintes sur l'avenir mais
vous serez dans le guinness le normand
je crois que endemol est en train de
faire homologuer ça prend beaucoup de
temps vous avez toujours des questions
incroyable
mais il faut les voir c'est
la nes mais mais vraiment c'est une
question s'est passé revient pas tout de
suite voilà on attend on a d'autres
questions en fait avant ouais c'est vrai
alors on va revoir le moment de cons
d'élimination c'est douloureux
c'est aujourd'hui après 250 de
participation est plus de huit mois deux
quotidiennes tués et éliminés par loris
étudiants en médecine à montpellier tu
lui en veulent aux risques
[Rires]
non mais quitte à perdre suis content
que ce soit un étudiant de 20 ans me dit
les gains seront bien utilisés étaient
moins bien jour là tu t'es tu ta des
métairies peur de perdre un moment où tu
te disais ça y est maintenant je suis un
mais plus d'un million d'euros d'un je
suis presque envie d'imiter plus qu'en
fait son esprit est plus en fait qu'on a
battu tous les records ouais à la fin on
n'a plus la fougue du début on n'est pas
comme si c'était un travail ah oui en se
disant alors certes c'est super rentable
givet puis à la fin tu fais la
circulation 6 1 et 2 millions avec toi
si tu es tombé thi ha mais oui depuis on
les tournages on commence en décembre
ouais donc depuis décembre voilà je
voyais les régisseurs on se racontait le
week end sera donc c'était vraiment des
collègues de travail et donc il y avait
du boulot ok la motivation du début
quand même et c'est quand même super
important pour rester concentré pour
rien donc peut-être qu'inconsciemment
j'étais déjà parti après avoir battu le
million soit étiqueté déjà peut-être est
un jeu aussi non mais c'est vrai mais
c'est vrai c'est toute façon c'est le
mental qui fait toute la différence
c'est pas vraiment la culture c'est plus
être à fond la rapidité est sérieux
quand tu peux avoir un mental
il faut quand même être turin moi j'ai
un mental tu te mets là bas j'ai pas
trop car encore un peu te dire alors on
va voir un regarde ton imitons les
minimes ton élimination il est tout
jeune c'est bien
en france où la quatrième république
quel était le titre du chef du
gouvernement
[Musique]
oui
messieurs il est monté de clarifier dans
l'hérault il a fait tomber aujourd'hui
maryse
ça a été une aventure extraordinaire
bruno mais quand je vois les proches de
l'eau riches si ému voilà je suis
vraiment ravi pour le riz ses sentiments
bien sûr et avéré très fair play de
votre part bruno
rival moi je vois ça
je te jure brûlot je crois comme
l'élimination je suis pas bien et toi
quand tu m'aimes toi je tique quand même
des émotions quand tu revois c'était en
plus de voir la mer de l'eau risque là
est mieux qu avait envie de pleurer et
c'est ce que je disais c'est take à la
fois moi c'était devenu un travail et
même pour les accompagnants en visio à
la fin ça faisait huit mois c'est devenu
une routine et malheureusement père
limite la valeur de l'argent et a
parfois tu fais des coups de maître tu
gagne 5000 euros c'était là sourire un
mode assez génial super ça qui fait on
se dit en fait on a perdu la fougue du
truc est las de voir ses proches super
émue qui font la fête je me dis bah
c'est ça dont l'émission a besoin c'est
de plus d'émotions et on avait peut-être
perdu ça un peu avec moi depuis quelque
temps bien sûr et c'est vrai que mais
bon là tu regrettes un peu juste encore
et m'a dit j'aurais peut-être dû me
battre un peu
après il a été très fort il avantage
c'est que je suis pas parti sur une
erreur d'étourderie jour là la question
président du conseil je l'avais c'est
juste que c'était pas assez rapides donc
comment je peux pas m'en vouloir en dix
ans mais je perds sur une grosse
connerie et je m'en veux pendant des
mois qu ans quand ça s'arrête comme ça
je suis sûr que la question que se
posent tous les téléspectateurs ça t'es
pas un énorme vide tu deviens pas une
rodez sont très fortes et très dur quand
même quand elle est éliminée 7 juillet
tu m'as dit c'est ça c'est pas c'est pas
dur après c'est vrai que ça fait des
mois que c'est ta routine et puis en
plus les tournages sont quand même très
long très prenant donc si vraiment tu
vivais que c'est incroyable ah ouais
c'est énormément d'argent tu répond à
des questions des fans de quiz donc
comment comment ça se passe à pitre
descente une petite d un petit peu de
pression c'est vrai qu'en plus comme
j'ai pas de travail j'ai pas de mec
j'avais tout seul du coup le lendemain
on sait le faire les autres
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la common law je ne te cache pas bruno
que tu songes beaucoup de caps
non là tu es petit peu l'étoile
mystérieuse
mais le million c'est ça qui est un
débat non plus je n'ai pas été bon ah
oui haïti c'est beau merci très beau
intelligent riches c'est comme un calme
toi quand même
avec un poteau mais c'est vrai il est
très beau gris trailer team bruit riche
souriant à chantilly c'est vrai que ce
manque à tous pour toi quels sont les
critères pour un homme
si ça met en perspective
je dirais cultiver grand bassin
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon
jeune homme avait de quoi donc non mais
battue est très utile non oui ben
intérêt et il cultive beaucoup d'un
petit
hôtel questions et voter non mais voilà
l'ultime est bon alors voilà est donc
logiquement bon bah c'est bon
alors je suis quelqu'un de quelqu'un de
mon âge sympa drôle à
ça pas drôle musclée ouais il a dit ça
va ça la savage et je sais pas parce que
dans l'ancien gagnant aujourd'hui
chroniqueur chez ruquier peut-être que
monsieur veut faire de la division un
petit peu avec grand plaisir à grand
succès je sais pas pour l'instant je
pense prendre un peu de recul comme
moi j'ai encore plein de questions à
poser je te dis franchement y'a plein de
gens les mauvaises langues le nitia ça
m'a énervé tu as vu qu'ils disaient oui
il est avantagé donc gilles verdez voilà
un joli enfin voilà nous on a toujours
des fonds du mes gilles verdez force et
ventes chez cegid vers des sites et
gilles verdez il est là pour faire chier
donc sk grognant toi tu t'es senti
avantages et où c'est chaud moi je pense
que c'est vraiment je vous le dis jamais
une forêt salle à la production ils
pensent pas c'est que après la vente
enfin ce que je me dis c'est qu'il ya
tous les maîtres de midi henri ça je
pense que cyril peut en témoigner
absolument tous les maîtres de midi et
dans toutes les émissions on ya tous les
champions il ya toujours cette critique
après déjà déjà c'est clair et net qui a
pas de triche dans le sens j'ai jamais
comme on l'entend parfois d'oreillettes
ya jamais les réponses écrites sur
l'écran blé donne pas à l'avance quoi
mais c'est pas pousser la production ce
cadre absolument un gros truc comme ça
de triche après souvent on se concentre
sur ce qu'on a envie de voir donc
évidemment si on regarde l'émission se
disant le maître de midi est avantagé
parce que là votre montage de montrer un
petit peu mais c'est vrai que des 12
coups dit à des questions ça va vraiment
dans tous les sens et après la le chef
du gouvernement soit quatrième
république je suis pas sûr que tout le
monde est la question d'après séquelles
fleuve coule à paris donc c'est sûr que
si on regarde que l'adolescent
si on regarde que la deuxième question
va dire évidemment l'avantagé mais les
j'ai l'impression que les gens fassent
aussi ont le même type de questions est
souvent nommés les questions dures que
j'ai donc est-ce que je suis plus ou
moins avantagées moi je reçois des
questions j'essaie d'y répondre ou pas
je ne m'amuse pas à tenir un listing du
niveau de difficulté mais je comprends
que quand il ya les gens soient là de
pendant des mois ça peut quand même
énervé les gens c'est beaucoup de
personnes aiment quand il ya du
renouveau quand ça change et c est donc
à la fin qu'on n'aime pas le champion en
place mais on va se concentrer que sur
ces aspects de la vie là on va voir que
ça marche c'est le champion c'est vrai
que là on attendait on était dans la
saga c'est vrai qu'on attendait le jour
où tout allait tomber et même sur dur et
on ne l'espérait pas mais c'est vrai que
voilà c'est ça qui fait aussi que les
autres c'était énorme estime m alors
bien sûr la plus la question que tout le
monde se pose c'est un million plus d'un
million d'euros de gains
que vas tu faire de tout cet argent non
mais qu'est ce tu vas faire c'est quoi
tes projets je pense la plupart va être
investi peut-être investissement locatif
reste et des appartements vers chez moi
dans le sud-ouest bien pour les mettre
en roquettes en location histoire dardé
petite rente régulière et donc le reste
placé assurance-vie voyage avant alors
j'ai à orlando prévue l'année prochaine
parce que je suis un immense fan de parc
d'attractions alors lui non il va chez
orlando
ces deux salles deux ambiances
et est ce que t'es pas là il était
proche mais oui voilà toute façon déjà
avec les cadeaux à six arénas eu
plusieurs voiles à montans vers les
voitures tôt faire des trucs mon cousin
oui sa voiture est tombée en panne donc
il a une voiture s'il n'a pas fait
exprès celui-là dans
le match juste sur les voitures etc puis
je vais me bruno bamba après souvent ce
sont électroniques électroménagers donc
ça sauve ressasse offre facilement à un
robot de cuisine je suis en salle de
jeux non est ce qu'il est est-ce que les
gens te reconnaissent dans la rue comme
disait si rythmique de sa fille que ça a
changé d'avis est ce que ça te dérange
ou est-ce que c'est plutôt sympathique
voici d'annoncer sa très bonne forme
star 2 152 jours et n'aura plus entre
trois et demi et 4 millions et demi de
téléspectateurs
donc quand ils ccc voilà c'est une
exposition incroyable quand tu sors dans
la rue on t'appelle commander la baisse
souvent les gens disent bruno c'est moi
et
non pas une question sérieuse mais non
parce que ils peuvent dire tiens c'est
le champion terminant vous voulez appel
vu que le voilà
non mais c'est vrai
quoi il ya souvent des gens qui
m'arrêtent en me disant je sais pas
votre prénom mais c'est vous le candidat
des 12 coups de midi c'est ça quand je
suis chez ma mère ou chez ma grand mère
elle vous regarde elle vous adore on
peut faire une photo enfin en vrai les
gens sont toujours gentille et
bienveillant et ça devient ça te dérange
parce que dirais tu peux plus me mine de
rien maintenant tu peux pas les faire
tes courses tant qu' après je suis pas
madonna m'attend ici par messi et
higuain très connu et c'est quoi tout le
monde le reconnaît non pas tout le monde
après il y en a plein qui travaillent le
midi qui sont passés à côté de tous et
un million et demi 4 millions de
personnes vient plus de camions parfois
c'est un truc de fou est ce que
c'est ça ça perturbe tout cet argent ou
bien ce que tu te dis non c'est je vois
là je jouais bien géré les gens vont pas
changer autour de moi c'est surtout ça
parce qu'on est maintenant parler un
instant avec notre psychologue vous êtes
manager vous êtes pour vous
[Applaudissements]
sur les
théories
vous êtes quoi
hip hip hop et l'inca et là tu vas voir
tu as gagné 1 million d'euros est battue
ne rase pas refaire
sa vie c'est à dire je vais gagner un
million avec lui mais je n'ai motors je
me suis posé deux questions que l'on
aime c'est la question du narcissisme
j'ai discuté avec eux dans les dans les
loges j'ai pas trouvé de problème
narcissique attend un vrai ouais ils
sont l'âme et darty ci par là
et au milieu
sont dans la balance je suis supposé une
autre question également sur l'addiction
aux jeux alors il ya effectivement chez
vous mais un un désir de de conquérir
l'intellect
[Rires]
autre chose et sa couleur oui alors par
l'addiction ça me fait penser aux jeux
de casino c'est à dire à quel moment on
va continuer à vouloir gagner mais avec
peut-être la pensée et voire même le
désir de perdre et là vous avez perdu
il a gagné un million
ces
jeux-là d'orge et 200 go et puis je vais
voir ce que je peux faire vous vous
réclamez de l'oseille c'est incroyable
ma fille ou alors je me rends pas compte
mais finalement pas tant que ça c'est un
peu comme cyril disait plus les potes ou
en effet quand tu fais un resto une
soirée ils disent allez c'est pour toi
mais sinon j'ai pas comme on le dit
souvent des jambes cet ancien ami du
collège ou du lycée qui te rappelle de
moi 4e b et des nouveaux
c'était ça prenait tellement de temps
les tournages vraiment c'était crevant
le week-end je faisais que me reposer
que dormir et je révisais je faisais des
fiches et c'est donc j'ai vraiment perdu
tant de vie sociale bruno ses toiles
c'est quoi les produits maintenant alors
c'est quoi la suite voilà est
officiellement sortie du jeu demain tu
vas sortir ça y est pour tout le monde
ait été plus dangereux c'est quoi tes
projets qu'est ce tu vas faire déjà
demain donc midi sur tf1 je viens
récupérer mon chèque géant adacore donc
le moment émouvant s'il avait envie de
me voir pleurer demain midi sur tf1 il
est bon on
va regarder mon épouse j'ai pas encore
touché tous les chèques donc encore très
bien travaillé avec tf1 non mais je
pense quand même si endemol qui paye
c'est la boîte de production et enfin
moi mes chèques s'était fait ça d'accord
ça marche
oui et non prendre un peu de recul voilà
comme je dis champion des jeux télé
c'est pas un métier donc retrouver ma
vie ma famille mes amis du repos placer
l'argent voilà comme disait acheter des
biens et puis après on verra travaillée
retravaillée comme 800g que trente ans
donc un effet pas passé 50 ans à nous
faire faire et tout ira bien perdre un
bouquet
que prévu et
m
[Applaudissements]
les instituts heureux oui tu peux
c'était une super aventure c'était
génial je rencontre plein de gens
c'était vraiment top on t'a pas proposé
de faire de la télé non absolument pas
presse était encore dans l'émission de
toute manière donc j'ai trois
entreprises ont proposé que ce thème
réfère en tout cas peut-être pas de
refaire un jeu télé tout de suite je
sais qu'il ya plein de champion qui
refont ses côtés
là ça fait neuf mois que j'étais je
pense là vraiment de faire une pause
après j'accepterai des propositions que
que si ça m'amusait que jamais dit ça
peut être sympa richesse que j'ai une
idée je te lis moi c'est bruno face à
tous les chroniqueurs c'est des
questions de culture générale eux ils
ont un ordinateur
c'est vrai on peut rechercher le il
s'est en fait puisque je te jure je vous
dis dès que j elle a enfin créé j'ai
vidé ses brûlots face à google c'est à
dire que y'a les chroniqueurs ils ont
google je lui pose une question si vous
trouvez la réponse avant lui il perd
l'argent sylvain canet trouve la réponse
avant vous il gagne l'argent c'est fait
franchement pas mal et je suis pas sûr
de pouvoir battre google met à bas les
chroniqueurs c'est sûr
eh bien